you know some stuff about me that's
pretty dark I'm sure that was pretty
weird I mean like a lot of the stuff
that was probably not TV friendly I
wrote her big enough stuff we'll find
out ready you ready but now my answer is
stretching out like Richard Simmons
I just felt something smoking and or
lounging lying on a cap we do know each
other we know each other very well
fudge-up [ __ ] oh yeah
I had the upbeat version of that I think
it's animate fun you got that song a
Canadian flare is it is it [ __ ]
like this is turned into a real
[ __ ] a no no that's not where
weirdo what do you got [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
face [ __ ] you thought was my favorites I
don't know I was just trying to think of
a word yeah I don't hear us were very
much I swear a lot really yeah not at me
no internally no I'm you should hear
what I'm saying right now
what is it
yeah very different if you think I'm
gonna do go why you should see me juggle
quickly I started running I don't know
what my secret talent is I'm gonna tell
you show yours first complaining or
tennis I really was one it's not most
likely to have jazz hands would you put
no I was what I'm most likely to succeed
oh you are I was voted most talkative
there you go
I can see that you're writing much
longer than well I drew a little picture
of your reaction to the thing - what are
you ready well I can't tell you
I wrote green things I wrote fish yeah I
know that for a while I was buying you a
green juice every day and then one day
you said don't ever do that again yeah
every honest I can't think of anything
that's what my look what our own I know
he's a nice very close I'm close and
you're right this is gonna sound sort of
tacky in small time but can we keep the
markers these are great mark amazing
larger his amazing markers